Donald Trump spent some time in a few
southern states in the last week he was
in Alabama supporting the now failed
Senate candidate Roy Moore but he also
went to Pensacola Florida where I
recently visited and our friends from
the Ring of Fire Network have their
studio there and in Pensacola Trump was
introduced by Republican state senator
Doug Broxson and the crowd went bonkers
in a positive way when Broxson alluded
to the end-times getting closer as a
result of Donald Trump recognizing
Jerusalem as the capital of Israel I've
mentioned this before and it's worth
mentioning again the right-wing
evangelical Christians that quote
support Israel support it for
Supernatural and delusional religious
reasons those evangelical Christians
aren't supporting or defending Jews to
the extent that they ever do because
they are against discrimination or
anti-semitism or whatever those
right-wing evangelicals support Israel
because they believe that they're
supportive Israel not of Jews as a
community is going to bring about the
second coming of Jesus or accelerate the
rapture or the end times or whatever
version of this delusion they subscribe
to so anyway Doug Broxson says when
introducing Trump that trumps Jerusalem
decision recognising Jerusalem as the
capital of Israel will get us more
quickly to the end times you've got to
understand what he's referencing when he
says it and the crowd just loves it
check it out President Trump promised to
protect their religious freedom uh-huh
now I don't know about you but when I
heard that Jerusalem where the king of
kings
the woman in the back we're soon coming
King is going to return back to
Jerusalem it's because of President
Trump declared Jerusalem to be the
capital of Israel
what's up with how Trump and some of
these other guys pronounced Jerusalem
remember Trump maybe it was because if
his whatever issue he was having with
his teeth during that speech but last
time we called it something like
truculent he has a tough time with
pronunciation and yeah it's it's not as
difficult so this is funny in two ways
first of all the king coming back to
Jerusalem is a reference to the end
times yet people are cheering I guess
it's because it means everyone dies and
the good Christians end up in heaven
while everyone else goes to hell when
the end times hit and I guess the people
standing behind Doug Broxson think that
they'll end up in heaven but it's also
funny because this is a political
decision by Trump right how could one
out of nearly 200 countries recognizing
a city as the capital of a country cause
Jesus to decide to come back is Jesus
waiting around for the right time to
come back to earth and when in 2017 one
president in one country said crucial um
is the capital of Israel well that does
it now Jesus is going to come back it's
just a it's really confusing to me when
I hear this logic they always just not
much about to happen - oh it's really
close you think it would have happened
by now I always get confused when I hear
about the end times and the rapture
because not having these evangelical
sensibilities myself for me when someone
says the rapture or the end times that
sounds bad not like something that I
want to see happen it really takes a
totally different world view and
barometer about life - here we're close
to the end times and to cheer that like
it's a good thing it's almost sad in two
ways one because they believed in all of
this but the second reason is that they
just don't seem to value their own lives
that much and apparently want this to
happen because they'll end up in heaven
they'll end up in heaven and all the bad
people are going to end up in hell and
and I guess for them that's some kind of
sweet justice or something like that